knock knock who's there doctor doctor
doctor who correct
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where we just
took a vote and decided that film and TV
theory was just way too long of a name
so just go with it oh I finally did it I
bought into the hype and who watched an
episode of Doctor Who then two then
three then three seasons I get it I see
the reasons for all the Time Lord love I
mean what's not to like about a
time-traveling dual hearted alien with a
super tool and an adorable accent am I
am I allowed to say that is a guy is
that okay or a show with the bollocks
that's right look at me using the
English isms to do episodes with plot
lines about things like dinosaurs on
freaking spaceships yeah and you thought
the new Jurassic Park looked cool so for
those of you who haven't drank the who
laid yet the show two picks The
Adventures of a mysterious and eccentric
Time Lord known as the doctor who
travels through time and space in his
time machine the TARDIS you know that
1950s blue British police box that shows
up as a design on everything from
bathrobes to jell-o molds yeah that
thing travels through time and space how
bigger on the inside other things to
know the doctor regenerates with a new
face every now and then when his
two-hearted body is about to die they're
currently on the 12th doctor or 13th
depends on how you look at it it's a
long story the doctor often travels with
his companions facing alien foes and
bizarre scenarios including the affer
mentioned dinosaurs on spaceships and
generally just helping people out and
riding wrong doings and there you go I
just caught you up on eight hundred
thirteen episodes spanning 52 years in
the space of one opening paragraph but
one question all the who viens on tumblr
want to know is whether a real-life Time
Lord can exist I'm sorry that was a typo
let's try it again
whether a real lifetime
word can exist in other words we're
gonna look at what makes a doctor a
doctor and from there to certain whether
or not those things are possible in the
realm of human experience but matpat I
hear you're angry blog rant now the
doctor is an alien and yes I know that
but since the doctor looks like a human
man in every single regeneration despite
having any alien race ever conceived as
a potential model and it still ends up
being a human we're sticking with that
so perhaps the better question for
today's episode is can a human fit the
bill and become a Time Lord so let's
look at some of the things that make
this guy and this guy and these guys and
maybe this guy tick one the doctor has
two working hearts that beat at 170
beats per minute - he has an internal
body temperature of 15 degrees Celsius
or 59 degrees Fahrenheit three abdi he
traveled through time and space in a
time machine before he has a sonic
screwdriver which functions as a deus ex
machina up sorry read that wrong a
do-it-all tool and five he regenerates
into a new body when he's dying and then
lives for hundreds of years
that is a lot and even for a show whose
average episode is five times that of
most other YouTube videos we can't cover
all that in one episode so let's been
some time today focusing on one element
that doctors biology lets me commit the
two heart thing otherwise known as a
binary vascular system believe it or not
there are actually numerous documented
incidences of actual humans being born
with two hearts this baby born in
Zimbabwe in 2013 for instance has two
hearts but also three legs four feet and
two heads and some other things that we
don't need to go into here but that's
not really what we're looking for more
commonly humans who have a faulty heart
get a second heart implanted on top of
the first one this is called a
heterotopic heart transplant and is done
so that the weak heart can rest and heal
take for instance Hannah Clark now
sixteen who had a second heart grafted
onto her own heart to save her life when
she was only two years old her original
heart had time to reset rebuild and is
now working just fine on its own or how
about the case of the 71
year-old man in Italy who lived through
dueling heart attacks in his two hearts
cue that Dueling Banjos music yep that's
about as much as we can play without
breaching copyright the trouble in this
case was that the man developed two
independent heart rhythms when the old
heart repaired itself to cure this
apparent dysrhythmia doctors gave him
medication which caused both hearts to
shut down now that my friends is quality
doctoring right there seal of approval
don't worry they figured it all out and
revived him with a defibrillator - both
hearts he's alive and well and drinking
plenty of Italian red wine which is
actually supposed to be really good for
your heart okay great so humans can live
with two hearts if they're specially
implanted by non who doctors but we're
talking about being born naturally with
two hearts is that possible we'll get
this it's not only possible we've all
lived with two hearts at some point in
our lives mind blown
when we humans are in the embryonic
stage of development we actually do have
two hearts this stage is called the
heart primordial the two hearts do
eventually fuse together into one heart
with four chambers but yes at some point
we've all had a binary vascular system
so knowing all this some curious
scientists in the 20s and 30s were able
to keep the heart from fusing in some
lab frogs and those little green guys
did grow up with two hearts and no
issues which I'm assuming just made them
more loving toward their frog parents in
humans though no similar experiments
have been done for obvious reasons and
in the case of heart defects nan who
doctors are able to find them and fix
them in utero so there aren't any
documented cases still we have been
shown to be able to live with two hearts
mark one for yes two Timelords existing
okay then so how about 170 beats per
minute thing seems kind of fast doesn't
it well again that's a big point in the
yes column the heart is a muscle and
it's contractions are known as
heartbeats right nothing are shattering
there while the refractory period of
cardiac muscle or the time it takes
between pulses is between 250 and 300
milliseconds this means that the heart
can be at its fastest at 200
to 240 beats per minute if your
heartbeat lingers at those high of raise
then you've probably got some issues to
attend to because it means the heart
isn't pumping blood efficiently or it
just means that you're a small child as
small children's hearts beat faster but
regardless that was pretty easy to prove
another point in the Time Lord category
you can have a heart beat at over 170
beats per minute so now let's move away
from the heart there's one more biologic
component to our Time Lord he's
incredibly low body temperature I mean
as winter fresh commercials have always
reminded me it's scorching 98.6 degrees
so can you drop that by nearly 40
degrees and still live to match the
doctors 59 degree internal temperature
let's see us humans aren't like
Gallifrey UNS we're incredibly sensitive
creatures mild hypothermia sets in at 95
degrees Fahrenheit amnesia at 91 and
loss of consciousness at 82 any body
temp below 70 and you're pretty much
screwed however there is one recorded
instance of an adult surviving a body
temperature of 56 point seven degrees
Anna Elizabeth Johansson back home a
Swedish radiologist or Time Lord in
disguise maybe who survived 80 minutes
in freezing water after a skiing
accident left her trapped under a layer
of ice during that time she had extreme
hypothermia and her body temperature
dropped to thirteen point seven degrees
Celsius 56 point seven degrees
Fahrenheit after being rescued and
transported by helicopter to a hospital
more than a hundred doctors and nurses
worked in shifts for nine hours to save
Anna's life she woke up 10 days later
after the accident paralyzed from the
neck down and then spent two months
recovering in an intensive care unit the
miraculous thing though is she's now
almost a hundred percent recovered and
that was the lowest body temperature in
history until another Swede a
seven-year-old named Stella survived
nearly drowning and getting down to 13
degrees Celsius that's fifty five point
four degrees Fahrenheit so what have we
learned here today that there is
something super weird about people
almost freezing to death in Sweden you
be careful out there PewDiePie oh and we
also learned that body temperature is
very very
very important and we can't really
function with just a few degrees of drop
but for the sake of the Doctor Who
argument we have two survivors with Time
Lord and temperatures so put a point in
the time lured column but just barely
maybe like 0.6 of a point or something
and there you have it we've just covered
the easy stuff we haven't even tackled
the complexities of time and space I was
born in the 49th century what
so grab your quantum spanner and watch
out for blorgons ah shoot right idea
wrong show your sonic screwdriver and
watch out for Daleks cuz next time we're
covering the subject of time and
specifically time travel but in the mean
time that's just a theory a TV theater
yeah it still doesn't work a film theory
and cut welcome to the super amazing and
card tournaments where I give you a fun
question to end the episode you vote and
I give you the results in a future
episode easy as that who doesn't like
having their opinions heard in an online
video forum this week it's a Whovian
villain throwdown who is the best Doctor
Who villain I mean there have been so
many over the years so let's narrow the
field down a bit to the top three the
weeping angels the Cybermen or the
Daleks will our tin can buddies have
what it takes to exterminate the
competition click on one to cast your
vote and get taken to the film theorist
channel page where you can subscribe
which I would recommend you do so that
way you know when part two of this
series comes out and to check out more
episodes over analyzing your favorite TV
shows and films I'm super sad about
everything that's going on here I hope
you are too
but in the meantime if you'll excuse me
I need to binge watch some community
that quantum spanner and blorgon joke at
the end got me in the mood for some
Inspector Spacetime